[Música]
'rusia recrudece su ofensiva en el
donbass y en el sur de ucrania las
autoridades indicaron que las tropas
rusas tomaron el control de la localidad
de criminal 100 kilómetros al sur de
tierra
la carrera a las presidenciales
francesas está lejos de haber terminado
y manuel mayo imagine bullpen se
preparan para el debate de este
miércoles los candidatos buscan
conquistar a los votantes indecisos
tenemos análisis
francia entregó la base militar de goce
ubicada en el norte del país al gobierno
de malí este paso hace parte de la
operación de retirada del contingente
francés en esa nación africana de nada
por el presidente manuel más con el
pasado mes de febrero
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en ucrania la
ofensiva en el este de ese país se
intensifica mientras moscú trata de
tomar el control de la región del
donbass el ejército del kremlin tomó la
ciudad de criminal y arremetió contra
lugansk y donestsk los ataques también
continúan en el noreste de esa nación en
jarkiv y en el sur en mykolaiv de otra
parte varios líderes mundiales
asistieron a una reunión virtual para
mostrar su apoyo al gobierno de kiev y
discutir nuevas sanciones contra rusia
marina sardiña con los detalles
se intensifican los combates en el este
de ucrania el kremlin está atacando con
dureza sectores residenciales en jarquín
ubicado a cerca de las líneas de
suministro de las fuerzas rusas que
avanzan sobre la región separatista del
donbass la intensidad del fuego de las
tropas rusas en la dirección de jarquín
bombas y la región de dnipropetrovsk ha
aumentado significativamente
intensificó la situación en mariupol
sigue siendo la más difícil posible sin
ningún cambio las tropas rusas bloquean
cualquier intento de organizar
corredores humanitarios salvar a la
gente a nuestra gente a los residentes
locales que están en manos de los
ocupantes
este martes moscú ofreció aquí es un
nuevo ultimátum de alto el fuego para
que las tropas ucranianas que todavía
resisten en la sitiada mariupol depongan
las armas y se rindan el mandatario
ucraniano señaló por su parte que sus
fuerzas lucharán hasta el final los
residentes que sobreviven en los
refugios subterráneos piden que se
respeten los corredores humanitarios
para evacuar la ciudad
y
quiero que todos los que estén viendo
este vídeo nos ayuden a organizar un
corredor humanitario para que podamos
salir de este lugar a salvo y vivos
tanto civiles como militares todos
luego de una reunión virtual de los
líderes occidentales que apoyan a volvió
a dirimir selenski hospi diada por el
presidente joe biden la casa blanca
anunció el envío de un nuevo paquete de
ayuda militar tienes 800 millones de
dólares a ucrania esta mañana me he
reunido con aliados y socios para hablar
de nuestro apoyo a ucrania frente a la
agresión rusa nos hemos comprometido a
seguir prestando asistencia y en poner
graves costes económicos a rusia y hemos
reafirmado nuestra solidaridad con el
pueblo ucraniano durante la reunión los
líderes discutieron a aumentar la
presión sobre el kremlin con más
sanciones y con un mayor aislamiento
diplomático algo que todavía no ha
frenado los brutales ataques de moscú
vamos a francia porque en la recta final
para la segunda vuelta de las
presidenciales
emanuel mccoy imagine lepén aún buscan
conquistar los votos de los indecisos y
de quienes apoyaron a otros candidatos
en la primera vuelta
de abril recordemos que en esa fecha
macon logró un 27 8 por ciento de los
votos y su contrincante la
ultraderechista marine lepén consiguió
el 23 1 % lo siguieron a jean-luc
mélenchon con 22% e ixe moore con 7,1
por ciento y baleares con 48 %
hablamos previamente con llama z
director del grupo de estudios de
democracia de la facultad de estudios
internacionales políticos y urbanos de
la universidad del rosario en bogotá
quien nos explicó hacia dónde podrían ir
los votos de jean-luc mélenchon iag que
se move y si la extrema derecha podría
llegar al elíseo
pues efectivamente los botones de melón
son tienen un poco la clave de esta
segunda vuelta o algo por lo menos en
gran parte
normalmente se van a dirigir más hacia
macro que hacia el open pero con una
buena proporción que puede efectivamente
más bien abstenerse o votar en blanco
cosa que evidentemente pues no no
ayudaría mucho a macro en esta segunda
vuelta si efectivamente pues el macro no
tiene a priori más reserva de votos que
que le pen le puede contar básicamente
sobre
los botones de ese muro y de otro
pequeño candidato de derecha nicola tipo
anterior y los demás en general pues han
tenido más bien hayan llamado más bien a
votar por macro pero pues la cuestión
acá es hasta qué punto esos votantes se
iban a movilizar por macro aunque de
todos modos es bastante impopular tiene
una imagen de candidato de las élites de
candidatos de los ricos que hace que
muchos electores particularmente los más
jóvenes o los electores de los sectores
populares esta extensión de yendo un
poco está esta segunda vuelta entonces
es
de todos modos una una segunda vuelta
que es mucho más apretada de lo que fue
la versión de 2017 en que macro no tenía
realmente una ventaja bastante fuerte
con respecto a lo tenãa y las encuestas
indican que todavía pues ganaría pero
pues con un margen ya mucho más estrecho
justamente en este contexto el
izquierdistas jean luc mélenchon ya hizo
un llamado a las elecciones legislativas
que se celebrarán en junio pidió a sus
seguidores votar masivamente para que su
partido francia en su misa logre
suficiente presencia en la asamblea
nacional para que él sea nombrado primer
ministro los franceses no eligen al
primer ministro es el nuevo presidente
el que lo designa sin embargo es
tradición que el mandatario elija a un
representante de la fuerza política más
votada en la asamblea nacional
yo de una frase de melilla con el
ministro
le pido al pueblo francés que me elijan
primer ministro escogiendo una mayoría
de resultados de la francia insumisa y
unión popular a su opinión
de algún llamado a todos aquellos que
quieren unirse a la unión popular es
decir la la esencia de su programa
unirse a nosotros en esta gran batalla
por lo que hay una tercera ronda no solo
una segunda ronda sino una tercera ronda
aliento y juventud y los invito a que
mañana miércoles sintonicen france24 a
las 14 horas de bogotá quito y lima para
la transmisión del debate presidencial
en francia y el posterior análisis con
mi compañera maría clara calle y
expertos
el ejército francés devolvió de manera
oficial a las fuerzas armadas de malí
las llaves de la base de goss y en el
norte del país africano esta entrega
hace parte de la primera etapa de la
retirada total de las tropas francesas
de territorio maliense por pedido del
presidente francés emmanuel mccomb el
retiro tiene lugar en medio de una
crisis diplomática entre parís y bamako
después de que la junta que gobierna
esta nación africana haya hecho uso de
los controvertidos mercenarios rusos del
grupo wagner
la salida de las tropas francesas de
malí continúa este martes el estado
mayor francés confirmó la restitución de
la base de gucci situada a 100
kilómetros al oeste de joe es la cuarta
base que regresa al control de las
fuerzas malienses después de tessalit
tumbuctú y kidal en el norte del país en
france 24 el portavoz del estado mayor
francés anunció la retirada total del
ejército francés de malí que tendrá
lugar de aquí hasta el fin del verano
wisco si marca la primera etapa
importante y retiro de mayo su búsqueda
transferir amenaza y después acabó de
aquí hasta el final de verano si al
final del verano ya no habrá soldados
franceses estacionados en mayo
extracción en bamako el pasado 19 de
febrero una multitud estalló de alegría
después de un anuncio de la junta en el
poder el día anterior los militares
pidieron afronte a retirar del país a
sus soldados de la fuerza abarcan
inmediatamente el enésimo episodio de
tensión entre parís y bamako desde el
golpe de estado de mayo de 2021 la junta
amaliense le reprocha a la fuerza de ser
ineficiente en la lucha contra el
terrorismo parís por su parte se niega a
trabajar en el mismo suelo que el grupo
de mercenarios rusos wagner llamado como
el esfuerzo por la junta maliense desde
bruselas bien compañeros sus socios en
la guerra en manuel ma q haya tomado
nota de la demanda maliense y ha
anunciado la salida de las tropas
francesas de mal y examen ahora las
fuerzas malienses van a tener que llevar
sus operaciones solas ya que esta
decisión tomada por el presidente de la
república resulta directamente de las
posiciones que tomaron las autoridades
malienses entonces ahora es su problema
manejar el combate contra los grupos
armados terroristas este lunes el
ejército maliense recibió un nuevo
cargamento de equipos rusos
incluyendo dos helicópteros de combate y
gradas
y el pintor y escultor colombiano
fernando botero uno de los principales
referentes del arte en la región y uno
de los artistas más importantes del
siglo 20 cumplió 90 años en la ciudad de
medellín cuna del maestro botero como es
llamado fue inaugurada la exposición
botero 90 años donde sus famosas y
voluminosas esculturas y pinturas son
protagonistas el artista siguió el
homenaje de forma virtual desde
montecarlo en mónaco
así llegamos al final de este
informativo volvemos en unos momentos
aquí en france 24
[Música]